we're here at Ben Higgins and Lauren
Bushnell's engagement party their show
happily-ever-after on freeform is
celebrating them tonight we're gonna
find out all about the latest that's
going on with their relationship I see
some people come after you guys for
living together before being married
have you seen those tweets and what's
your response yeah I mean I think it's
fair I think a lot of people are judging
us for that because of you know our
faith and we we don't hide the fact that
we're Christians and and I think when
when we decided to live together is
really because our life it started out
so abnormally and it was going to be
very difficult for us to spend time
together with how fast our lives are
moving and so at any amount of time we
could be together to get to know each
other better which I think God would
desire for us to is before we make that
ultimate commitment to know you know to
know each other well and living together
gave us that opportunity what I say it's
been the wisest and smartest thing at
all times no and I think we could both
say that at times it's caused us you
know issues and it's been confusing but
overall I'm really glad we did it and I
would stand firm that it was the right
decision you guys have been doing such a
media circus for this show yeah are you
tired yet will you get a vacation
anytime soon what are the plans if so Oh
glad you asked I can only dream of it
we're actually leaving in a few days
here for a vacation or very first
vacation together no cameras no one else
I'm tagging along um we're gonna go hang
out on an island on the beach we're just
gonna go and hang out the first time
together and relax and we actually are
getting massages on the beach